Jill starts off this hour in Missouri
hey Jill how are you hi Dave I am fine
thanks for taking my call and thanks for
all you do um my situation here did I'm
48 I've never married I don't have kids
I am a full-time music director for a
church I make 46,000 so when I started
up to you I realized there's no way I'm
going to be able to take care of all my
bills and get ahead with that so I
actually started teaching high school
band and choir and so that added another
10,000 a year now the problem is is that
they're requiring me to get certified to
go back to school and that's going to
cost the program that I had I am gonna
be taking is going to be like twelve
thousand ten thousand dollar job yeah
but it's over over a number of years
they're allowing me five years to do it
okay but I don't know I don't know what
else I mean is it's feasible right now I
have my house is 98 thousand I have a
ten thousand dollar car payment there
Clark's 46,000 on student loan and
fourteen on a credit card but I'm
hanging on you said you're under 48 I am
48 yes
okay so I think there's a bigger
question okay the bigger question is
what do you want to be doing for the
next ten years and let's invest in that
oh I would not go to all this angst and
trouble over a part-time job okay now if
you want to be a full-time music teacher
and make that your career and you're
going to go in and become a member of
that County and they're gonna pay you
fifty sixty thousand overtime seventy
thousand dollars to go work for them and
that's the return and you get to live
your dream and you get to smile while
you're doing it and you get to make
money and it's a full-time gig then a
twelve thousand dollar investment makes
sense
so I've got another investment for a
$10,000 part-time job does not make any
sense at all because you'll be the first
thing on the chopping block if there's a
budget problem
sure it's a pretty new schools that
started up so right now it's part-time
but the attendance is tripling I mean
doubling every year and so we in private
school
it is a private school and I are
anticipating that it will be a full-time
your music director is a Christian
school he did yeah all right well
there's two things out weren't there
then one is I would want to discuss with
them the idea that they pay for this
okay which they can afford it and be
where it's going to take me after I go
to this trouble okay and based on the
growth of students we think we're gonna
make you full time in two years if you
finish your certification then let's get
her done you know but if I if they think
well you know I don't know and it might
be 20 years and we all know and well
then you don't invest in no I'm not
gonna put my life on the line for that
but but is this certification
transferable then to public yes yeah
that's going to pay for it it's only 12
grand okay and in return you'll promise
to work there you know okay and you go
ahead and enjoy to settle on your future
salary and stuff okay so let's no
worries let's make this a part of a 10
year game plan not a way to keep my
part-time job sure okay then it makes
sense
mm-hmm okay all right thank you so much
thank you for the call we appreciate you
joining us